on évoquait le désarroi des new yorkais
il y a aussi un débat en ce qui concerne
les enfants
faut-il parler et comment faut-il parler
du 11 septembre à l'école
beaucoup ont réfléchi à ce sujet c'est
un reportage de stéphane bret maire et
olivier robert comme d'habitude
la journée commence par le salut au
drapeau et ce matin la voix des enfants
résonne un peu plus fort le collège
d'hoboken s'apprête à commémorer les
attaques du 11 septembre un premier
anniversaire particulier de l'école on
pouvait voir les tours jumelles
ici il y a deux cents élèves 200 témoins
directs de la catastrophe pour cet
hommage aux victimes
les plus petits ont pris leur pastel du
rouge et beaucoup de noirs là c'est
quand l'avion est ce que la première
tour il veut tous ces gens blessés tous
ces enfants qui avaient besoin dead et
là ce sont les camions de pompiers qui
essayent de maîtriser le feu
quand tu envie d'oublier à cause de tous
ces policiers qui sont morts en essayant
de sauver des vies un long silence puis
des blessures qui se roule
parfois je suis terrifiée pensé que ça
pourrait se produire un réseau mais le
pire c'est qu'on ne sait pas où ça se
passerait alors on ne se sent plus en
sécurité nulle part il ça c'est très
effrayant aura demandé aux écoles
d'évoquer la tragédie les professeurs et
de leurs élèves à surmonter cette
douleur qui refait surface
mais celle qui dirige le collège est
perplexe face à cette initiative voix et
des bananes ne purent pas éviter d'en
parler mais je me demande si c'est bon
pour les enfants car maintenant on
entend parler d'autres attentats
possible et cela ne fait qu'entretenir
l'angoissent des enfants face à la mort
demain tous les élèves se réuniront dans
le parc d'hoboken juste en face de
ground zero une cérémonie du souvenir
pour les 45 habitants de la ville qui
ont péri dans les décombres du world
trade center